many stores will open Thursday night for
shoppers looking to get a jump on Black
Friday sales retailers rely on those
sales to help generate profits Alex
Wagner shows us how brick-and-mortar
stores are finding new ways to survive
in a changing retail landscape Alex good
morning good morning guys almost 16
million Americans work in retail so it
is an essential part of the US economy
but many stores the so called
brick-and-mortar retailers are
struggling against online competition
this year dozens of retailers have filed
for bankruptcy that has some of the
survivors looking for creative ways to
get you and your money in the door at
the Eddie Bauer store in Columbus Ohio
the retail environment is decidedly
chilly freezing in fact this is an
actual block of ice it is I'm gonna sit
on it give it a shot
they created an ice box chilled to 16
degrees so customers can try out their
cold-weather gear it's something that
can't be done online people come here on
repeat visits absolutely for the novelty
to test out the clothes well yes to test
the outerwear for sure that's what it's
intended for it's just a great
experience a great way to punish
children punish children like Eddie
Bauer retailers across the country are
looking for ways to lure customers
offline and into their stores so the
brands that are winning have figured
that out and are creating unique
experiences for the consumer in the
store Melissa Miller is with Alliance
Data which helps businesses market to
customers and try to retain them it
could be a makeover
it could be meet the chef it could be
decorating services it's why Saks had
its Weller e pop-up part fitness center
part shopping experience and Macy's is
partnering with Samsung and its flagship
store in New York
hopes that virtual reality turns into
actual sales American brick-and-mortar
retail is undergoing seismic change and
the numbers tell the tale of woe in 2017
alone retail mainstays like Sears and
Kmart have closed more than 350 stores
the gap has closed about 200 and JC
Penney has shuttered nearly 140 well
this is the the current retail
apocalypse mark Cohen is a professor at
Columbia Business School he says it's
not just the Amazon's of the world that
are hurting traditional stores
what about brick-and-mortar retailers
who are now trying to get into the
e-commerce game many of the legacy
retailers the department stores for
example who've created their own
websites are now finding their core
customer migrating over to the website
empty stores aren't sustainable but
novel efforts to coax customers through
the doors come with risks well if it
seems like a gimmick today's customer
sees right through it they might check
it out once but they're not going to be
responsive to it and more so than ever
before they have choices increasingly
they can transact anywhere in the world
just with the stroke of a key for some
stores it's already too late
photographers Seth lawless documents the
collapse of the American Mall it's
always a very eerie and creepy walking
into any abandoned structure especially
in abandoned mall the decline in
traditional retail is certainly
reshaping American commerce but it may
also end up reshaping American life
these places weren't just a place to
shop right it was a communal space we
went here we met friends this is a way
we actually communicated with each other
this was a chat room before there was a
chat room it is estimated that in the
next five years one in four u.s. malls
will close so the efforts to get people
to shop in stores is all the more urgent
makes me so sad I used to love going to
the mall yes walk around even even if
you didn't buy anything dirty the public
square where people came together and
that is all the first jobs there
lutely so is it making a difference for
people to come in and poke around to try
stuff out I mean I think in some ways
this is a little bit of a Hail Mary
we'll see the numbers do not tell us
definitively one way or the other as yet
so we'll follow it all right Alex thank
you very much